This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Seattle is a city with plenty of well-known tourist attractions. The space needle, Pike Place Market, the Seattle Art Museum. Today though, I'm venturing out in the rain to visit a different sort of Seattle attraction. It's an office building called the Bullet Center. I'm here to meet Brian Court, one of the architects. Hey Brian, Shankar. Shankar, nice to meet you. Very nice to meet you. Thank you for doing this at Chalk Notice.
This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Seattle is a city with plenty of well-known tourist attractions. The space needle, Pike Place Market, the Seattle Art Museum. Today though, I'm venturing out in the rain to visit a different sort of Seattle attraction. It's an office building called the Bullet Center. I'm here to meet Brian Court, one of the architects. Hey Brian, Shankar. Shankar, nice to meet you. Very nice to meet you. Thank you for doing this at Chalk Notice.|||这里是 Hidden Brain，我是 Shankar Vedantam。西雅图是一座拥有众多知名旅游景点的城市。太空针塔、派克市场、西雅图艺术博物馆。不过今天，我要冒着雨去参观一种不同类型的西雅图景点。这是一座名为“公牛中心”（Bullet Center）的办公大楼。我是来见布赖恩·考特的，他是建筑师之一。嘿，布赖恩，我是 Shankar。Shankar，很高兴认识你。很高兴认识你。谢谢你抽空接受采访。
Brian and I are headed to the top floor. My first instinct is to find the elevator, but it's nowhere in sight. Did you forget to put an elevator in the building, Brian? We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair or you're not able to climb the building, Brian? We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair or you're not able to climb the stairs, you just hit the button there with the wheelchair and that door will open, but we were trying to give people an option to take the stair first. Those stairs, there are six floors of Douglas Forsteps built on an outer wall of the building.
Brian and I are headed to the top floor. My first instinct is to find the elevator, but it's nowhere in sight. Did you forget to put an elevator in the building, Brian? We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair or you're not able to climb the building, Brian? We do have an elevator through the door to the left. If you're in a wheelchair or you're not able to climb the stairs, you just hit the button there with the wheelchair and that door will open, but we were trying to give people an option to take the stair first. Those stairs, there are six floors of Douglas Forsteps built on an outer wall of the building.|||布赖恩和我正前往顶楼。我的第一直觉是找电梯，但它无处可寻。布赖恩，你是不是忘在楼里装电梯了？穿过左边的门确实有一部电梯。如果你坐轮椅或者不能爬楼，布赖恩？穿过左边的门我们确实有一部电梯。如果你坐轮椅或者无法爬楼梯，你只需按下带有轮椅标志的按钮，那扇门就会打开，但我们试图为人们提供一个首先走楼梯的选择。那些楼梯，是建在大楼外墙上的六层道格拉斯冷杉台阶。
Each floor has expansive landings that allow people to congregate and chat. The best views at the bullet center are not from the CEO's office. You get those views when you climb what people here refer to as the irresistible staircase. So you walk into the stair enclosure. You look up, you see the stair all the way up
Each floor has expansive landings that allow people to congregate and chat. The best views at the bullet center are not from the CEO's office. You get those views when you climb what people here refer to as the irresistible staircase. So you walk into the stair enclosure. You look up, you see the stair all the way up|||每一层都有宽敞的平台，供人们聚集和聊天。公牛中心最好的风景并不是从首席执行官的办公室看到的。当你攀登这里的人们所说的“不可抗拒的楼梯”时，你就能看到这些风景。所以你走进楼梯间。你抬头向上看，能看到直通顶部的楼梯。
to the sixth floor of the building. And that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair enclosure, you look up, you see the stair all the way up to the sixth floor of the building. And that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair. The designers wanted to build a staircase that would help people become healthier. Their intuition was that if the stairs were appealing and prominent, people would use them. What you see as you climb to the sixth floor are sweeping views of Seattle. You'll notice as we get higher views of this city really start to unfold. This corner of the project site had some of the best views you can see out now to the west and then the downtown skyline directly to the south.
to the sixth floor of the building. And that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair enclosure, you look up, you see the stair all the way up to the sixth floor of the building. And that's hopefully going to draw you up the stair. The designers wanted to build a staircase that would help people become healthier. Their intuition was that if the stairs were appealing and prominent, people would use them. What you see as you climb to the sixth floor are sweeping views of Seattle. You'll notice as we get higher views of this city really start to unfold. This corner of the project site had some of the best views you can see out now to the west and then the downtown skyline directly to the south.|||直达大楼第六层。希望这能吸引你走上楼梯间，你抬头向上看，能看到直通大楼第六层的楼梯。希望这能吸引你走上楼梯。设计师们想要建造一个能帮助人们变得更健康的楼梯。他们的直觉是，如果楼梯既吸引人又显眼，人们就会使用它们。当你爬到第六层时，映入眼帘的是西雅图的全景。你会发现，随着我们越爬越高，这座城市的景色真正开始展现在眼前。项目地点的这个角落拥有一些最好的视野，你现在向西望去，然后正南面就是市中心的林立高楼。
By putting a stair here we're able to really capitalize on views all the way from the east around to the west. So far Brian says this irresistible staircase seems to be living up to its name. We've actually got data that's showing us that just about two-thirds of the people that go to the sixth floor on a daily basis are taken the stair over the elevator. Most buildings place the elevator's front and center as you walk inside. Most of us don't even think to look for the stairs when we enter an office building. By making the stairs prominent and keeping the elevators out of sight, the bullet center is trying to get people to develop new behaviors. Sometimes, unexpected things happen as you climb these stairs. You bump into people,
By putting a stair here we're able to really capitalize on views all the way from the east around to the west. So far Brian says this irresistible staircase seems to be living up to its name. We've actually got data that's showing us that just about two-thirds of the people that go to the sixth floor on a daily basis are taken the stair over the elevator. Most buildings place the elevator's front and center as you walk inside. Most of us don't even think to look for the stairs when we enter an office building. By making the stairs prominent and keeping the elevators out of sight, the bullet center is trying to get people to develop new behaviors. Sometimes, unexpected things happen as you climb these stairs. You bump into people,|||通过在这里设置楼梯，我们能够充分利用从东到西的全方位美景。布赖恩说，到目前为止，这座“不可抗拒的楼梯”似乎名副其实。我们实际得到的数据显示，每天去第六层的人中，大约有三分之二的人选择走楼梯而不是坐电梯。大多数建筑在你走进去时都会将电梯放在最显眼的正中央。我们大多数人在进入办公楼时甚至都不会想到去寻找楼梯。通过让楼梯显眼并将电梯隐藏起来，公牛中心正试图引导人们养成新的行为习惯。有时候，当你爬这些楼梯时，意想不到的事情会发生。你会撞见人，
you didn't think you'd meet. That's Rashad Morris. He walked down a flight of stairs to come say hello. He told me he takes the stairs nearly every day and he often has chance interactions on them that turn out to be very enjoyable. Do you actually think about it each day that you're saying I want to take the stairs or is it just sort of an unconscious decision at this point? There are sometimes when I'm coming from downtown and I've walked all the way up Capitol Hill and I get to the door of the building and I think oh man another six flights but then I think you know I don't get a whole lot of exercise in my day-to-day work life anyway and so this is worth it and I enjoy the view always. There's a word for such behaviors. They're habits. This week on Hidden Brain,
you didn't think you'd meet. That's Rashad Morris. He walked down a flight of stairs to come say hello. He told me he takes the stairs nearly every day and he often has chance interactions on them that turn out to be very enjoyable. Do you actually think about it each day that you're saying I want to take the stairs or is it just sort of an unconscious decision at this point? There are sometimes when I'm coming from downtown and I've walked all the way up Capitol Hill and I get to the door of the building and I think oh man another six flights but then I think you know I don't get a whole lot of exercise in my day-to-day work life anyway and so this is worth it and I enjoy the view always. There's a word for such behaviors. They're habits. This week on Hidden Brain,|||是你没想到会遇到的人。那是拉沙德·莫里斯（Rashad Morris）。他走下一段楼梯来打招呼。他告诉我他几乎每天都走楼梯，而且经常在楼梯上发生一些最终非常愉快的偶遇。你每天都会刻意去想“我要走楼梯”吗，还是说现在这只是一种无意识的决定？有时当我从市中心过来，一路走到国会山（Capitol Hill），然后来到大楼门口时，我会想，天哪，又是六层楼，但接着我会想，你知道的，我日常工作生活中本来就没有太多锻炼，所以这是值得的，而且我一直很喜欢这里的风景。这种行为有一个词来形容。它们就是习惯。本周的 Hidden Brain，
we consider how habits shape who we are and how we can use them to become the people we'd like to be. You probably know someone like this in your life. The person who gets a ton of things done, eats healthy food and stays in shape. People like Chris Trigger from the TV series Parks and Recreation. I have to go run 10 miles. I have run 10 miles a day, every day, for 18 years. That's 65,000 miles. A third of the way to the moon. My goal is to run to the moon. Picture a guy who strips off his workloads to reveal a running outfit underneath. Now, Chris Trigger is a fictional character exaggerated for comedic effect. But we all know someone like this, a friend or colleague
we consider how habits shape who we are and how we can use them to become the people we'd like to be. You probably know someone like this in your life. The person who gets a ton of things done, eats healthy food and stays in shape. People like Chris Trigger from the TV series Parks and Recreation. I have to go run 10 miles. I have run 10 miles a day, every day, for 18 years. That's 65,000 miles. A third of the way to the moon. My goal is to run to the moon. Picture a guy who strips off his workloads to reveal a running outfit underneath. Now, Chris Trigger is a fictional character exaggerated for comedic effect. But we all know someone like this, a friend or colleague|||我们探讨习惯如何塑造了我们，以及我们如何利用习惯成为我们想成为的人。你生活中可能也认识这样的人。那个能完成大量工作、吃健康食品并保持身材的人。就像电视剧《公园与游憩》（Parks and Recreation）中的克里斯·特里格（Chris Trigger）那样的人。我得去跑10英里。我18年来每天都跑10英里。那是65,000英里。到月球三分之一的路程。我的目标是跑向月球。想象一个脱掉外衣露出里面跑步装备的家伙。当然，克里斯·特里格是一个为了喜剧效果而夸张的虚构角色。但我们都认识这样的人，一个朋友或同事，
or spouse who consistently performs the tasks that seem so hard to the rest of us. How do they do it? What do they have that the rest of us lack? According to Wendy Wood, a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California, characters like Chris Trigger are not magical unicorns. They just have a secret. They are expert at building good habits. In her book, Good Habits, Bad Habits, the science of making positive changes that stick, Wendy argues that we can all become experts at building good habits and dismantling bad ones.
or spouse who consistently performs the tasks that seem so hard to the rest of us. How do they do it? What do they have that the rest of us lack? According to Wendy Wood, a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California, characters like Chris Trigger are not magical unicorns. They just have a secret. They are expert at building good habits. In her book, Good Habits, Bad Habits, the science of making positive changes that stick, Wendy argues that we can all become experts at building good habits and dismantling bad ones.|||或者配偶，他们总是能完成对我们其他人来说似乎很难的任务。他们是怎么做到的？他们拥有什么而我们其他人却缺乏？根据南加州大学心理学和商学教授温迪·伍德（Wendy Wood）的说法，像克里斯·特里格这样的人物并不是什么神奇的独角兽。他们只是拥有一个秘密。他们是建立好习惯的专家。在她的书《好习惯，坏习惯：持久改变的科学》（Good Habits, Bad Habits）中，温迪认为我们都可以成为建立好习惯和打破坏习惯的专家。
If we only stop to understand the psychology behind our routines. Wendy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, I'm thrilled to be here. I want to start with something that you once saw on Facebook. Your cousin went on Facebook and announced that she was going to change her life by which she meant she wanted to lose some weight. Why did she announce this on Facebook?
If we only stop to understand the psychology behind our routines. Wendy, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, I'm thrilled to be here. I want to start with something that you once saw on Facebook. Your cousin went on Facebook and announced that she was going to change her life by which she meant she wanted to lose some weight. Why did she announce this on Facebook?|||只要我们停下来去理解日常行为背后的心理学。温迪，欢迎来到 Hidden Brain。哦，很高兴来到这里。我想从你在 Facebook 上看到的一件事开始。你的表妹在 Facebook 上宣布她要改变生活，她的意思是她想减肥。她为什么要在这个上面宣布？
And what was the reaction she garnered from her friends? So I think by making a public statement, she was trying to commit herself to the initial idea, her initial desire to lose weight. In a way, she sort of upped the stakes because she made it public, and then she was accountable to all of her Facebook friends. And they were highly supportive. They spurred her on, and told her how strong she was.
And what was the reaction she garnered from her friends? So I think by making a public statement, she was trying to commit herself to the initial idea, her initial desire to lose weight. In a way, she sort of upped the stakes because she made it public, and then she was accountable to all of her Facebook friends. And they were highly supportive. They spurred her on, and told her how strong she was.|||她从朋友那里得到了什么反应？所以我认为，通过公开表态，她是在试图让自己致力于最初的想法，即她最初减肥的愿望。从某种程度上说，她提高了赌注，因为她将其公开了，然后她必须对她所有的 Facebook 朋友负责。他们非常支持她。他们鼓励她，并告诉她她有多坚强。
So she got a lot of positive reinforcement for that. And the feedback from her friends, this idea that, in the idea of encouraging her or telling her, just do it, you know that reminds me of a video made by the actor, Shia LaBuff. He stands in front of a green screen, and he says, well, actually let me just play for you what he says.
So she got a lot of positive reinforcement for that. And the feedback from her friends, this idea that, in the idea of encouraging her or telling her, just do it, you know that reminds me of a video made by the actor, Shia LaBuff. He stands in front of a green screen, and he says, well, actually let me just play for you what he says.|||因此，她为此获得了大量的积极强化。来自朋友们的反馈，这种鼓励她或告诉她“放手去做”（just do it）的想法，你知道，这让我想起了演员希亚·拉博夫（Shia LaBuff）制作的一段视频。他站在绿幕前说，嗯，实际上让我把他说的话放给你们听听。
Take a listen. Yesterday, you said tomorrow, so just do it. Make your dreams come true. Just do it. This message is going to be so pervasive when it comes to making changes in our life. The idea that if you want to make a change, all you have to do is just say, just do it. Wouldn't that be wonderful? I don't think that's most of our experience, but what we do believe is if we wanted to enough,
Take a listen. Yesterday, you said tomorrow, so just do it. Make your dreams come true. Just do it. This message is going to be so pervasive when it comes to making changes in our life. The idea that if you want to make a change, all you have to do is just say, just do it. Wouldn't that be wonderful? I don't think that's most of our experience, but what we do believe is if we wanted to enough,|||听一听。昨天你说的是明天，所以放手去做吧。让你的梦想成真。放手去做。当涉及到我们生活中的改变时，这种信息将是如此普遍。如果你想做出改变，你所要做的就是说一句“放手去做”。那不是很美好吗？我认为这并不是我们大多数人的经历，但我们坚信的是，如果我们足够渴望，
we'd exert enough willpower and we'd make it happen. And the result, though, is that it doesn't often because willpower is not actually, we have found, the best way to achieve our goals and to change our behavior. Talk about this idea, Wendy, that significant numbers of Americans believe that the way to change their behavior is through self-control, that willpower is the key to either making changes that stake or to making changes that fail to stick. Yeah. It's something that pervades our culture. When surveys are done of Americans and their beliefs
we'd exert enough willpower and we'd make it happen. And the result, though, is that it doesn't often because willpower is not actually, we have found, the best way to achieve our goals and to change our behavior. Talk about this idea, Wendy, that significant numbers of Americans believe that the way to change their behavior is through self-control, that willpower is the key to either making changes that stake or to making changes that failure to stick. Yeah. It's something that pervades our culture. When surveys are done of Americans and their beliefs|||我们就会施展足够的意志力，让它成为现实。然而结果却是，这种情况并不经常发生，因为我们发现，意志力实际上并不是实现目标和改变行为的最佳途径。温迪，谈谈这个观点：相当多的美国人认为改变行为的方式是通过自我控制，意志力是做出能够坚持的改变还是无法坚持的改变的关键。是的。这是充斥在我们文化中的一种东西。当对美国人及其信仰进行调查时发现，
about how to change behavior, particularly something like obesity, three-quarters of Americans think that it's a problem with self-control and willpower that we just don't have enough. And if we had more more we'd all be thinner Now researchers have actually looked at this question and asked how much will power is central You cite the work of the late great psychologist Daniel Wagner who once ran a study where he told people not to think about a White bear why did you do that and what did he find he did it to show that Why did you do that and what did he find? He did it to show that if you try not to think about something, even something as trivial
about how to change behavior, particularly something like obesity, three-quarters of Americans think that it's a problem with self-control and willpower that we just don't have enough. And if we had more more we'd all be thinner Now researchers have actually looked at this question and asked how much will power is central You cite the work of the late great psychologist Daniel Wagner who once ran a study where he told people not to think about a White bear why did you do that and what did he find he did it to show that Why did you do that and what did he find? He did it to show that if you try not to think about something, even something as trivial|||关于如何改变行为，特别是像肥胖这样的问题，四分之三的美国人认为这是自我控制和意志力的问题，即我们拥有的还不够。如果我们拥有更多，我们都会变得更瘦。现在，研究人员实际上已经研究过这个问题，并探讨了意志力到底有多核心。你引用了已故伟大的心理学家丹尼尔·瓦格纳（Daniel Wagner）的工作，他曾做过一项研究，告诉人们不要去想一只白熊，你为什么要这样做，他又发现了什么？他这样做是为了表明……你为什么要这样做，他又发现了什么？他这样做是为了表明，如果你试图不去想某事，甚至是一件像……
as a white bear that you wouldn't normally think about, then later when you're given an opportunity to think about it again, you just can't stop. It's a white bear, white bear, white bear. So this tells us something about what it's like to try to repress or control our desires. Yes we can do it in the short run, but ultimately it backfires. Those ideas get a life of their own and they start to obsess us. And when you think about the behaviors we often want to change in our lives, quitting, smoking, or eating health
as a white bear that you wouldn't normally think about, then later when you're given an opportunity to think about it again, you just can't stop. It's a white bear, white bear, white bear. So this tells us something about what it's like to try to repress or control our desires. Yes we can do it in the short run, but ultimately it backfires. Those ideas get a life of their own and they start to obsess us. And when you think about the behaviors we often want to change in our lives, quitting, smoking, or eating health|||白熊那样你平时不会去想的事情，那么后来当你得到机会再次去想它时，你就根本停不下来了。是白熊，白熊，白熊。所以这告诉了我们一些关于试图压抑或控制我们的欲望是什么感觉的事情。是的，我们在短期内可以做到，但最终会适得其反。这些想法有了自己的生命，并开始让我们魂牵梦绕。当你想到我们经常想要改变的生活中的行为时，比如戒烟、戒烟，或者健康饮食，
fear, or exercising more regularly, the challenge of course is not to make a one-time change, not to exercise well just today. The challenge of course is to make a long-term change, and the research would then suggest that willpower might not be the most effective way to go about achieving that. Yes, that's actually how I got into this whole research area. I was interested in understanding what it is that helps people persist. So how do people persist, at say, eating healthfully or saving more money or getting more sleep? We can all do this one time or two times, but it's a very different thing to do it on a consistent basis. When I first started this research, the idea was
fear, or exercising more regularly, the challenge of course is not to make a one-time change, not to exercise well just today. The challenge of course is to make a long-term change, and the research would then suggest that willpower might not be the most effective way to go about achieving that. Yes, that's actually how I got into this whole research area. I was interested in understanding what it is that helps people persist. So how do people persist, at say, eating healthfully or saving more money or getting more sleep? We can all do this one time or two times, but it's a very different thing to do it on a consistent basis. When I first started this research, the idea was|||或者更规律地锻炼，挑战当然不是做一次性的改变，不是仅仅今天锻炼好。挑战当然是做出长期的改变，而研究随后表明，意志力可能并不是实现这一目标的最高效方式。是的，这实际上是我进入整个研究领域的契机。我有兴趣了解是什么帮助人们坚持下去。那么人们是如何坚持健康饮食、存更多钱或获得充足睡眠的呢？我们所有人都可以做一两次，但要持续不断地做到这一点，则是完全不同的另一回事。当我刚开始这项研究时，想法是
that we did these things when we were sufficiently committed, when we had enough self-control to follow through, then we'd form these strong intentions and we'd act on them over time. But I'd noticed that it didn't really play out that way in my life. I've often made decisions that I didn't follow through with, even though I was initially very committed to those decisions, and I have a pretty good amount of willpower. So what we did is we did a large review of the research to test whether people's decision-making was important all the way through behavior change process, not just from the beginning, where my cousin started on Facebook declaring she's going to change, but also two, three months later. And what we found was really surprising.
that we did these things when we were sufficiently committed, when we had enough self-control to follow through, then we'd form these strong intentions and we'd act on them over time. But I'd noticed that it didn't really play out that way in my life. I've often made decisions that I didn't follow through with, even though I was initially very committed to those decisions, and I have a pretty good amount of willpower. So what we did is we did a large review of the research to test whether people's decision-making was important all the way through behavior change process, not just from the beginning, where my cousin started on Facebook declaring she's going to change, but also two, three months later. And what we found was really surprising.|||当我们有足够的决心，当我们有足够的自我控制力去执行时，我们就会做这些事情，然后我们会形成强烈的意图，并在一段时间内付诸行动。但我注意到，在我的生活中情况并非如此。我经常做出没有贯彻到底的决定，尽管我最初对这些决定非常坚定，而且我有相当多的意志力。所以我们做的是对研究进行了广泛的回顾，以测试人们的决策是否在整个行为改变过程中一直都很重要，不仅仅是从一开始——也就是我表妹在 Facebook 上宣布她要改变的时候，而且在两、三个月后也是如此。而我们发现的结果真的令人惊讶。
Decision making, our intentions, our thoughts, our commitment, they're very important when we start to change. That's what determines whether we do behaviors once in a while, continuing over time, took something very different. And we didn't know what it was to start off with. It was like once you start performing a behavior it just sort of continues on its own.
Decision making, our intentions, our thoughts, our commitment, they're very important when we start to change. That's what determines whether we do behaviors once in a while, continuing over time, took something very different. And we didn't know what it was to start off with. It was like once you start performing a behavior it just sort of continues on its own.|||决策、我们的意图、我们的想法、我们的决心，在我们开始改变时都非常重要。这决定了我们是偶尔做一次这种行为，而要长期持续下去，则需要完全不同的东西。一开始我们并不知道那是什么。这就好比一旦你开始执行某种行为，它就会自行延续下去。
It's like action begets action. And what we decided was this is kind of like driving your car, right? So every once in a while you do pay attention and make decisions, but most of the time when you're driving, it's sort of in the background. You're thinking about something other than what you're doing. Your actual responses don't take much thought and decision. They're certainly not taking your willpower.
It's like action begets action. And what we decided was this is kind of like driving your car, right? So every once in a while you do pay attention and make decisions, but most of the time when you're driving, it's sort of in the background. You're thinking about something other than what you're doing. Your actual responses don't take much thought and decision. They're certainly not taking your willpower.|||就像行动产生行动一样。我们得出的结论是，这有点像开车，对吧？所以你偶尔确实会集中注意力并做出决定，但大多数时候当你开车时，它有点像是在后台运行。你在想别的事情，而不是你正在做的事情。你的实际反应不需要太多的思考和决定。它们肯定不需要消耗你的意志力。
It's a counterintuitive idea. Conscious willpower is not the driving force behind sustained behavior change. That idea is powerfully illustrated by an experiment conducted in Germany that ask two simple questions. Are people who stick to their resolutions, the people who see lots of temptations, but have the willpower to resist them? Or are they the kind of people who've set up their lives so they don't even notice the temptations? They found that contrary to all of our expectations, that people who are high achievers, who we think of as having good willpower, good self-control,
It's a counterintuitive idea. Conscious willpower is not the driving force behind sustained behavior change. That idea is powerfully illustrated by an experiment conducted in Germany that ask two simple questions. Are people who stick to their resolutions, the people who see lots of temptations, but have the willpower to resist them? Or are they the kind of people who've set up their lives so they don't even notice the temptations? They found that contrary to all of our expectations, that people who are high achievers, who we think of as having good willpower, good self-control,|||这是一个违反直觉的想法。有意识的意志力并不是维持行为改变的驱动力。德国进行的一项实验有力地说明了这一观点，该实验提出了两个简单的问题。那些坚持新年决心的人，是那些看到很多诱惑但有意志力去抗拒它们的人吗？还是那种把生活安排得甚至注意不到诱惑的人？他们发现，与我们所有人的预期相反，那些高成就者——我们认为他们拥有良好意志力和良好自控力的人——
they didn't actually experience many temptations. They weren't conflicted by having lots of desires that were inappropriate and things they didn't want to do. That was the people who were low in self-control. The people who weren't that successful at achieving their goals in life. In other words, this is not a case of people who have cake in the refrigerator and are very good at resisting opening the refrigerator to eat the cake, these are just people who don't have cake in the refrigerator. Exactly, or if they do they don't see it. They have coded that as, okay, that's my kid's cake.
they didn't actually experience many temptations. They weren't conflicted by having lots of desires that were inappropriate and things they didn't want to do. That was the people who were low in self-control. The people who weren't that successful at achieving their goals in life. In other words, this is not a case of people who have cake in the refrigerator and are very good at resisting opening the refrigerator to eat the cake, these are just people who don't have cake in the refrigerator. Exactly, or if they do they don't see it. They have coded that as, okay, that's my kid's cake.|||实际上并没有经历太多的诱惑。他们并没有因为拥有许多不恰当的欲望和不想做的事情而感到内心冲突。那是自控力低的人。那些在实现生活目标方面不太成功的人。换句话说，这不是那种冰箱里有蛋糕并且非常擅长忍住不打开冰箱吃蛋糕的人，这些人只是冰箱里根本没有蛋糕。没错，或者如果他们有，他们也看不到。他们将其编码为：好吧，那是给我孩子吃的蛋糕。
I don't eat that. I eat the fruit, and I like the fruit. How do they do it? It turns out that when you build a habit, it's like putting on a set of unconscious mental blinders. Once in place, the blinders protect you from temptations and distractions. The more you ignore those temptations, the stronger the blinders become. To put this another way, habits are self-reinforcing. They can be difficult to start, but once in place,
I don't eat that. I eat the fruit, and I like the fruit. How do they do it? It turns out that when you build a habit, it's like putting on a set of unconscious mental blinders. Once in place, the blinders protect you from temptations and distractions. The more you ignore those temptations, the stronger the blinders become. To put this another way, habits are self-reinforcing. They can be difficult to start, but once in place,|||我不吃那个。我吃水果，而且我喜欢水果。他们是怎么做到的？事实证明，当你养成一个习惯时，就像戴上了一副无意识的心智眼罩。一旦戴上，眼罩就能保护你免受诱惑和分心的干扰。你对这些诱惑越不在意，眼罩就会变得越牢固。换句话说，习惯是自我强化的。它们可能很难开始，但一旦养成，
they have a life of their own because they stop being conscious and become automatic and unconscious. In fact, once you have developed a habit, you will stick to it even if the alternative is objectively easier. Wendy has a nice example of this from her own life. She sometimes goes biking with a friend who's a professional cyclist. Yeah so she and I were good friends and we'd love to talk about our families and just exchange information about our lives and that would happen as we started the bike ride. Now she's a professional cycl, so you might wonder what she's doing riding with me. Well, I rode with her on her days off when she was supposed to be just not breaking a sweat.
they have a life of their own because they stop being conscious and become automatic and unconscious. In fact, once you have developed a habit, you will stick to it even if the alternative is objectively easier. Wendy has a nice example of this from her own life. She sometimes goes biking with a friend who's a professional cyclist. Yeah so she and I were good friends and we'd love to talk about our families and just exchange information about our lives and that would happen as we started the bike ride. Now she's a professional cycl, so you might wonder what she's doing riding with me. Well, I rode with her on her days off when she was supposed to be just not breaking a sweat.|||它们就有了自己的生命，因为它们不再是有意识的，而是变得自动化和无意识的。事实上，一旦你养成了习惯，即使客观上有更简单的选择，你也会坚持下去。温迪在自己的生活中有一个很好的例子。她有时会和一位身为职业自行车手的女性朋友一起骑车。是的，她和我是好朋友，我们喜欢谈论我们的家庭，交流彼此生活的信息，这些都会在我们开始骑自行车时发生。现在她是一名职业自行车手，所以你可能会好奇她怎么会跟我一起骑车。嗯，我在她休息日和她一起骑车，当时她本该只是轻松骑行、不出汗的。
And that was fine, you know, because that's the speed I ride at. And so we'd have a good time talking and chatting, and then after we'd been cycling for maybe an hour and a half, she would start speeding up. And she did this consistently. And I tried not to take it personally, because you can't talk to somebody who's cycling that fast. And I asked her at the end of one of our rides, so what happens at the end?
And that was fine, you know, because that's the speed I ride at. And so we'd have a good time talking and chatting, and then after we'd been cycling for maybe an hour and a half, she would start speeding up. And she did this consistently. And I tried not to take it personally, because you can't talk to somebody who's cycling that fast. And I asked her at the end of one of our rides, so what happens at the end?|||那挺好的，你知道的，因为那是我的骑行速度。所以我们聊得很开心，然后在我们骑了一个半小时左右之后，她开始加速。她一直都是这样做的。我尽量不把它放在心上，因为你没法和骑得那么快的人聊天。我在我们的一次骑行结束时问她，那么最后发生了什么？
Because I kind of lose you. And she said, well, I'm just so tired at going at the slow pace. I can't control my actions anymore, and I just naturally speed up. So what this indicates, I think it's a fascinating example, because it indicates that the habit is not necessarily the easiest thing, or the low effort thing to do, instead, is what you usually do that you fall back on. There have been anecdotal accounts of how long it takes to develop a habit, and you and
Because I kind of lose you. And she said, well, I'm just so tired at going at the slow pace. I can't control my actions anymore, and I just naturally speed up. So what this indicates, I think it's a fascinating example, because it indicates that the habit is not necessarily the easiest thing, or the low effort thing to do, instead, is what you usually do that you fall back on. There have been anecdotal accounts of how long it takes to develop a habit, and you and|||因为我有点跟不上你。她说，嗯，以慢速度骑行让我太累了。我再也无法控制自己的行为了，我就会自然而然地加速。所以这表明，我认为这是一个引人入胜的例子，因为它表明习惯不一定是最简单的事情，也不是最省力的事情，相反，它是你通常会做的事情，是你习惯性退回的状态。关于养成一个习惯需要多长时间，有一些轶事般的说法，你和
others have had the insight that this number is probably not the same for different kinds of habits. That some habits in some ways are easier to form than others, perhaps they have larger rewards than others. What does the science tell us about how long it takes to develop different habits like exercising or writing or going to the gym? Habits are cognitive associations, they're mental associations that we form when we repeat an action over and over again in a given context and then get a reward.
others have had the insight that this number is probably not the same for different kinds of habits. That some habits in some ways are easier to form than others, perhaps they have larger rewards than others. What does the science tell us about how long it talented it takes to develop different habits like exercising or writing or going to the gym? Habits are cognitive associations, they're mental associations that we form when we repeat an action over and over again in a given context and then get a reward.|||其他人都有这样一种洞察力：对于不同种类的习惯，这个数字可能并不相同。有些习惯在某些方面比其他习惯更容易形成，也许它们比其他习惯具有更大的回报。科学告诉我们，培养像锻炼、写作或去健身房这样不同的习惯需要多长时间？习惯是认知联想，是我们当在一个特定语境中一遍又一遍地重复某种动作并获得奖励时形成的心理联想。
When you do that, you are learning very slowly and incrementally to associate that context with that behavior. So the next time you're in that context, the behavior automatically comes to mind. You might be very consistent in how you repeat an action, and I might be more variable. And if I'm more variable, it's going to take longer to form that habit, that mental association in mind.
When you do that, you are learning very slowly and incrementally to associate that context with that behavior. So the next time you're in that context, the behavior automatically comes to mind. You might be very consistent in how you repeat an action, and I might be more variable. And if I'm more variable, it's going to take longer to form that habit, that mental association in mind.|||当你这样做时，你正在非常缓慢且循序渐进地将该语境与该行为联系起来。因此，下次你处于该语境中时，这种行为就会自动浮现在脑海中。你在重复动作时可能非常一致，而我可能更多变。如果我更多变，形成这种习惯、这种心智联想所需的时间就会更长。
But also for complex behaviors, for things that have many different parts, it takes longer to form a habit. And the best evidence we have at this point is from a study that had people add a simple health behavior to their day, adding something like a glass of water took two months to become automated so that you don't have to make decisions about it. Something like going to the gym could take, ooh, three, four months before, of going every day, before it becomes really habitual
But also for complex behaviors, for things that have many different parts, it takes longer to form a habit. And the best evidence we have at this point is from a study that had people add a simple health behavior to their day, adding something like a glass of water took two months to become automated so that you don't have to make decisions about it. Something like going to the gym could take, ooh, three, four months before, of going every day, before it becomes really habitual|||而且对于复杂的行为，对于包含许多不同部分的事情，形成习惯需要更长的时间。我们目前拥有的最好证据来自于一项研究，该研究让人们在日常生活中增加一项简单的健康行为，比如增加一杯水，需要两个月的时间才能实现自动化，这样你就不必为此做出决定。像去健身房这样的事情可能需要，噢，三、四个月的时间天天去，才能真正变成一种习惯，
in the sense that you don't have to think. You just do. So one implication of this is that just as you can have good habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly, you can also develop bad habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly. You mentioned another neighbor friend of yours who sometimes has to decide whether to drive to her kids school or walk to her kids school and that revealed something really interesting about the power of habit. Yeah, so we lived in a small neighborhood and the school was actually right next to her house.
in the sense that you don't have to think. You just do. So one implication of this is that just as you can have good habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly, you can also develop bad habits that cause you to do things unthinkingly. You mentioned another neighbor friend of yours who sometimes has to decide whether to drive to her kids school or walk to her kids school and that revealed something really interesting about the power of habit. Yeah, so we lived in a small neighborhood and the school was actually right next to her house.|||也就是说你不需要思考。你直接去做就行了。因此，这意味着，正如你可能会拥有让你不假思索地做事的良好习惯一样，你也会养成让你不假思索地做事的坏习惯。你提到了你的另一个邻居朋友，她有时必须决定是开车送孩子去学校还是走路去学校，这揭示了关于习惯力量的一些非常有趣的事情。是的，我们住在一个小社区里，学校实际上就在她家隔壁。
One night at a parent-teacher conference, I watched her get into her car and drive to the school parking lot, which was actually further from the front door, the school than her house. Her habit was to get in the car and this was in Texas, so it was hot. So if she'd been thinking she would have been very cognizant of the weather and that she was actually going to be uncomfortable for longer if she took her car than if she walked. There's an underlying subtext to many of these stories, and that subtext is that in much of our lives, our actions are actually not being driven by conscious and deliberate intention.
One night at a parent-teacher conference, I watched her get into her car and drive to the school parking lot, which was actually further from the front door, the school than her house. Her habit was to get in the car and this was in Texas, so it was hot. So if she'd been thinking she would have been very cognizant of the weather and that she was actually going to be uncomfortable for longer if she took her car than if she walked. There's an underlying subtext to many of these stories, and that subtext is that in much of our lives, our actions are actually not being driven by conscious and deliberate intention.|||有一天晚上在家长会上，我看着她上车，然后开车去学校停车场，其实那个停车场比她家离学校正门还要远。她的习惯就是上车，而且这是在德克萨斯州，天气很热。所以如果她当时在思考，她就会非常清楚天气情况，并且知道如果她开车，她实际感到不舒服的时间会比走路更长。许多这些故事背后都有一个潜在的潜台词，这个潜台词是，在我们生活的很大一部分时间里，我们的行动实际上并不是由有意识和刻意的意图驱动的。
And that's a subtext that runs through much of your book, this idea that much of our lives actually is being run on autopilot. Yes. One of the first studies we did, we tried to figure out what percentage of daily actions are habitual in the way that you describe. And what we found is that about 43% of everyday actions are done repeatedly, almost every day in the same context. Again, it's very much like driving. We have this general sense that we're doing things but
And that's a subtext that runs through much of your book, this idea that much of our lives actually is being run on autopilot. Yes. One of the first studies we did, we tried to figure out what percentage of daily actions are habitual in the way that you describe. And what we found is that about 43% of everyday actions are done repeatedly, almost every day in the same context. Again, it's very much like driving. We have this general sense that we're doing things but|||这也是贯穿你大部分书籍的一个潜台词，即我们生活的大部分时间实际上都是在自动驾驶状态下运行的。是的。我们做的第一批研究之一，是试图弄清楚日常行动中有百分之多少像你所描述的那样具有习惯性。我们发现，大约 43% 的日常行动是在相同的语境下几乎每天重复进行的。再次强调，这非常像开车。我们有一种总体感觉，觉得我们在做事，但是
it's not driven by an active decision-making process. So the interesting thing is that because we don't acknowledge or often recognize how powerful these unthinking forces are, in many of our campaigns, our public health campaigns, for example, we focus primarily on changing people's conscious beliefs and attitudes. And you have some really interesting ideas on how this plays out when it comes to getting people to eat right. You've looked at, for example, campaigns to get people to eat more fruits and vegetables, what do you find?
it's not driven by an active decision-making process. So the interesting thing is that because we don't acknowledge or often recognize how powerful these unthinking forces are, in many of our campaigns, our public health campaigns, for example, we focus primarily on changing people's conscious beliefs and attitudes. And you have some really interesting ideas on how this plays out when it comes to getting people to eat right. You've looked at, for example, campaigns to get people to eat more fruits and vegetables, what do you find?|||它并不是由积极的决策过程驱动的。所以有趣的是，因为我们不承认或经常认识到这些不用大脑思考的力量有多么强大，所以在我们的许多活动中，例如公共卫生运动中，我们主要集中于改变人们有意识的信念和态度。对于如何让人们正确饮食，你有一些非常有趣的见解。例如，你研究过让人们多吃水果和蔬菜的活动，你发现了什么？
Yeah, probably one of the most famous campaigns actually started here in California, five a day, eating five a day fruits and vegetables. Five a day, five a day, we all know that's the healthy one. Fruits and vegetables, and they're okay, are healthy with the survival of the day. When it began in the 1990s, only 8% of the U.S. population realized that they needed to eat five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. Five years later, it over a third of Americans understood they need deep five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. But when you look at what people were doing, the campaign looks really different.
Yeah, probably one of the most famous campaigns actually started here in California, five a day, eating five a day fruits and vegetables. Five a day, five a day, we all know that's the healthy one. Fruits and vegetables, and they're okay, are healthy with the survival of the day. When it began in the 1990s, only 8% of the U.S. population realized that they needed to eat five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. Five years later, it over a third of Americans understood they need deep five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. But when you look at what people were doing, the campaign looks really different.|||是的，最著名的运动之一实际上是从加利福尼亚州开始的，“每天五份”，每天吃五份水果和蔬菜。一天五份，一天五份，我们都知道那是健康的。水果和蔬菜，它们没问题，对一天的生存很健康。当它在 20世纪90年代开始时，只有 8% 的美国人口意识到他们每天需要吃五份水果和蔬菜。五年后，超过三分之一的美国人明白他们需要每天吃五份水果和蔬菜。但当你看看人们在做什么时，这项活动看起来大不相同。
So before the campaign started, 11% of us were actually eating five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. 10 years later, still 11%. tables a day, 10 years later, still 11 percent. And even more recent assessments have shown that Americans are declining from that point, fewer and fewer of us are eating that amount. And part of the reason for this is much of our eating is habitual. We do it automatically, we shop automatically, we only go down certain aisles in the grocery store, people might not even go down the produce aisle. So they're not going to be influenced by this abstract thought. Yes, fruits and vegetables are good for me. Instead, they're eating based on the environment that they're in, and the
So before the campaign started, 11% of us were actually eating five servings of fruits and vegetables a day. 10 years later, still 11%. tables a day, 10 years later, still 11 percent. And even more recent assessments have shown that Americans are declining from that point, fewer and fewer of us are eating that amount. And part of the reason for this is much of our eating is habitual. We do it automatically, we shop automatically, we only go down certain aisles in the grocery store, people might not even go down the produce aisle. So they're not going to be influenced by this abstract thought. Yes, fruits and vegetables are good for me. Instead, they're eating based on the environment that they're in, and the|||所以在活动开始前，我们当中实际上有 11% 的人每天吃五份水果和蔬菜。10年后，依然是 11%。每天吃几份蔬菜，10年后，依然是 11%。甚至更新的评估也表明，美国人正在从那个时间点开始下降，越来越少的人吃那个数量。部分原因在于我们的饮食很大程度上是习惯性的。我们自动地进食，自动地购物，我们在杂货店里只走某些过道，人们甚至可能根本不会走到生鲜区。因此，他们不会受到这种抽象想法的影响。是的，水果和蔬菜对我有益。相反，他们的进食是基于他们所处的环境，以及
patterns they've developed. I mean, I feel like I see this in so many different campaigns where the idea is if we can change people's beliefs, their behavior will follow. And of course, intuitively, that's a very appealing idea, but really, the evidence doesn't seem to support it? No, I mean, it does support it for one-off behaviors, limited behaviors, single-time behavior change. So if you're trying to get people to sign up for a program, for example, then convincing people to do it and giving them the opportunity right when you convince them is probably a pretty effective way to do it. But so many
patterns they've developed. I mean, I feel like I see this in so many different campaigns where the idea is if we can change people's beliefs, their behavior will follow. And of course, intuitively, that's a very appealing idea, but really, the evidence doesn't seem to support it? No, I mean, it does support it for one-off behaviors, limited behaviors, single-time behavior change. So if you're trying to get people to sign up for a program, for example, then convincing people to do it and giving them the opportunity right when you convince them is probably a pretty effective way to do it. But so many|||他们养成的模式。我的意思是，我感觉在如此多的不同活动中都能看到这一点，其核心思想是，如果我们能改变人们的信念，他们的行为就会随之改变。当然，直观地说，这是一个非常吸引人的想法，但实际上，证据似乎并不支持这一点？不，我的意思是，它确实支持一次性行为、有限行为、单次行为改变。因此，如果你试图让人注册一个项目，那么说服人们去做，并在说服他们的那一刻给他们机会，可能是一个非常有效的方法。但是有这么多的
of health behaviors, of financial behaviors, relationships, productivity, these things involve long-term change in behavior, and that you don't get by convincing people to do things. So if conscious beliefs and intentions don't get people to change their behavior, how can we use science to start habits or break them? That's when we come back. Stay with us. When the Wood is a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California, she says corporations are increasingly drawing on insights about habits to influence their workforce. One example, Uber.
of health behaviors, of financial behaviors, relationships, productivity, these things involve long-term change in behavior, and that you don't get by convincing people to do things. So if conscious beliefs and intentions don't get people to change their behavior, how can we use science to start habits or break them? That's when we come back. Stay with us. When the Wood is a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California, she says corporations are increasingly drawing on insights about habits to influence their workforce. One example, Uber.|||健康行为、财务行为、人际关系、生产力，这些事情都涉及行为的长期改变，而这并不是通过说服人们做事就能实现的。因此，如果意识到的信念和意图并不能让人们改变行为，我们如何利用科学来培养习惯或打破习惯？我们稍后回来。请继续收听。温迪·伍德是南加州大学的心理学和商学教授，她说企业正越来越依靠对习惯的洞察来影响其员工队伍。一个例子是优步（Uber）。
Being a driver on Uber is difficult in many ways, right? You're taking your own personal car and you are using it for business. You have a bunch of strangers sitting in the back. So Uber would put a lot of money into training and evaluating drivers and their cars and then drivers would quit after, well, before they got to ten rides. And so Uber would lose money. So what they decided to do was they decided to automate, and you've probably heard this, when you're in an Uber at the end of your ride, the phone app pings and then assigns the driver to the next ride. So they don't have time to think and maybe decide, okay, this is getting difficult time of pings and then assigns the driver to the next ride.
Being a driver on Uber is difficult in many ways, right? You're taking your own personal car and you are using it for business. You have a bunch of strangers sitting in the back. So Uber would put a lot of money into training and evaluating drivers and their cars and then drivers would quit after, well, before they got to ten rides. And so Uber would lose money. So what they decided to do was they decided to automate, and you've probably heard this, when you're in an Uber at the end of your ride, the phone app pings and then assigns the driver to the next ride. So they don't have time to think and maybe decide, okay, this is getting difficult time of pings and then assigns the driver to the next ride.|||在优步当司机在很多方面都很艰难，对吧？你开着自己的私家车将其用于商业用途。后座坐着一堆陌生人。因此，优步会投入大量资金来培训和评估司机及其车辆，然后司机就会辞职，嗯，在跑满十单之前就辞职了。因此优步会亏钱。所以他们决定做的是实现自动化，你可能也听说过这一点，当你坐在优步车里行程结束时，手机应用会发出蜂鸣声，然后为司机指派下一单。所以他们没有时间去思考并可能决定，好吧，这变得很困难了……应用发出蜂鸣声然后为司机指派下一单。
So they don't have time to think and maybe decide, okay, this is getting difficult time going home. They're off on their next ride. And so it moves them forward through the process to the point where they start feeling more comfortable with what they're doing. And they can develop some habitual patterns of dealing with customers.
So they don't have time to think and maybe decide, okay, this is getting difficult time going home. They're off on their next ride. And so it moves them forward through the process to the point where they start feeling more comfortable with what they're doing. And they can develop some habitual patterns of dealing with customers.|||所以他们没有时间去思考并可能决定，好吧，现在很难熬，想回家了。他们已经踏上了下一趟行程。因此，它推动他们在整个流程中不断前进，直到他们开始对所做的事情感到更加适应。并且他们可以培养出一些与客户打交道的习惯性模式。
So there's an important insight here, and this is an insight that's useful not just for, a multi-billion dollar business, trying to manipulate the behavior of its workforce, but it's an insight that affects all of us. When I'm sitting on my couch and I'm watching Netflix, at the end of each episode of Netflix, I don't actually have to press any buttons. Netflix tells me in nine seconds, the next episode is going to start.
So there's an important insight here, and this is an insight that's useful not just for, a multi-billion dollar business, trying to manipulate the behavior of its workforce, but it's an insight that affects all of us. When I'm sitting on my couch and I'm watching Netflix, at the end of each episode of Netflix, I don't actually have to press any buttons. Netflix tells me in nine seconds, the next episode is going to start.|||这里有一个重要的见解，这个见解不仅对试图操纵其员工行为的数十亿美元企业有用，而且对我们所有人都有影响。当我坐在沙发上看 Netflix 时，在 Netflix 的每一集结束时，我实际上不需要按任何按钮。Netflix 告诉我，9秒钟后，下一集就要开始了。
And that's really the same idea as what Uber is doing to his drivers. It's basically saying, you can change people's behavior by essentially making it frictionless for them to keep doing the behavior. Yes. Yeah. And that is essentially what most commercial industries have figured out how to do at this point in one way or another. Will you have fries with that? Is probably the classic example of encouraging certain behaviors, making behaviors easy, consumption, spending money. You can think of so many examples of this
And that's really the same idea as what Uber is doing to his drivers. It's basically saying, you can change people's behavior by essentially making it frictionless for them to keep doing the behavior. Yes. Yeah. And that is essentially what most commercial industries have figured out how to do at this point in one way or another. Will you have fries with that? Is probably the classic example of encouraging certain behaviors, making behaviors easy, consumption, spending money. You can think of so many examples of this|||这实际上与优步对其司机做的事情是同一个道理。它基本上是在说，你可以通过本质上为人们继续这种行为扫清阻碍（无摩擦），来改变人们的行为。是的。是的。这基本上就是大多数商业行业在这一点上已经以这样或那样的方式弄清楚如何做的事情。你要来份薯条吗？这大概是鼓励某些行为、使行为变得简单、消费、花钱的经典例子。你可以想到很多这样的例子
in our modern culture. I wonder if we can take this insight Wendy, and apply it to how you can actually start to build habits. So in exactly the same way that corporations in some ways manipulate us into doing what they want us to do. I want to explore how we might be able to manipulate ourselves into doing things that we think are good for us. Yeah, so we all know that people are most likely to repeat actions that are easy for them
in our modern culture. I wonder if we can take this insight Wendy, and apply it to how you can actually start to build habits. So in exactly the same way that corporations in some ways manipulate us into doing what they want us to do. I want to explore how we might be able to manipulate ourselves into doing things that we think are good for us. Yeah, so we all know that people are most likely to repeat actions that are easy for them|||在我们现代文化中。温迪，我想知道我们是否可以借鉴这种见解，并将其应用到你如何真正开始培养习惯中去。就像企业在某些方面操纵我们去做他们想让我们做的事情一样。我想探讨我们如何能够操纵自己去做我们认为对我们有益的事情。是的，所以我们都知道，人们最有可能重复那些对他们来说很容易的行动，
and actions that are fun. So, if you really don't like going to the gym, then you're not going to do it very often. And you need to figure out something to do to make it more fun. Making it easy is also critical. So there is a study that is quite amazing, I think, but it has been replicated a couple of times on how far people travel to the gym. If people travel about three and a half miles, then they are likely to go to the gym five times a month on average. If people travel five miles, then they're likely to go only once a month on average. Wow.
and actions that are fun. So, if you really don't like going to the gym, then you're not going to do it very often. And you need to figure out something to do to make it more fun. Making it easy is also critical. So there is a study that is quite amazing, I think, but it has been replicated a couple of times on how far people travel to the gym. If people travel about three and a half miles, then they are likely to go to the gym five times a month on average. If people travel five miles, then they're likely to go only once a month on average. Wow.|||以及有趣的行动。所以，如果你真的很讨厌去健身房，那么你不会经常去。你需要想出点办法让它更有趣。使其变得简单也至关重要。因此，有一项研究我认为非常惊人，但它已经被重复过好几次了，关于人们去健身房要走多远的路。如果人们路程大约三英里半，那么他们平均一个月可能会去健身房五次。如果人们路程五英里，那么他们平均一个月可能只会去一次。哇。
The five miles presents friction. The 3.5 miles is much less friction and makes the behavior more likely. We just don't have to struggle so much to get there, and anything that reduces the struggle and the stress is going to make habits more likely to form. I don't know if you noticed this, but Wendy and I have mentioned a specific word a couple of times in the last few minutes. Friction. When things are difficult to do, they have high friction. When doing something is effortless, there's low friction.
The five miles presents friction. The 3.5 miles is much less friction and makes the behavior more likely. We just don't have to struggle so much to get there, and anything that reduces the struggle and the stress is going to make habits more likely to form. I don't know if you noticed this, but Wendy and I have mentioned a specific word a couple of times in the last few minutes. Friction. When things are difficult to do, they have high friction. When doing something is effortless, there's low friction.|||五英里的路程带来了阻力。3.5英里的阻力小得多，更有可能促成这种行为。我们不需要为到达那里而挣扎那么多，任何能减少挣扎和压力的东西都会使习惯更有可能形成。我不知道你有没有注意到这一点，但在过去的几分钟里，我和温迪多次提到过一个特定的词。阻力（Friction）。当事情很难做时，它们的阻力就高。当做某事毫不费力时，阻力就很低。
It turns out this word is incredibly important to understand how habits work. One unusual study revealed the power of friction using stale popcorn. We did it in a local movie theater. We had the movie patrons watch a bunch of trailers and rate them for us. This summer, experience the life of the world's greatest
It turns out this word is incredibly important to understand how habits work. One unusual study revealed the power of friction using stale popcorn. We did it in a local movie theater. We had the movie patrons watch a bunch of trailers and rate them for us. This summer, experience the life of the world's greatest|||事实证明，这个词对于理解习惯是如何运作的至关重要。一项不同寻常的研究利用隔夜的爆米花揭示了阻力的力量。我们在当地的一家电影院做了这个实验。我们让观影者观看了一堆预告片并为我们打分。这个夏天，体验世界上最伟大的人的生活……
athlete. Every day, millions of people go through the same routine while life passes them by. Coming soon for a summer. And supposedly as compensation, we gave them boxes of popcorn to eat. Now, unbeknownst to them, some got stale popcorn, which we had popped earlier and kept in our lab for a week in a plastic bag. So it was pretty bad. And others got boxes of fresh popcorn to eat. And so, we had a week in a plastic bag. So it was pretty bad.
athlete. Every day, millions of people go through the same routine while life passes them by. Coming soon for a summer. And supposedly as compensation, we gave them boxes of popcorn to eat. Now, unbeknownst to them, some got stale popcorn, which we had popped earlier and kept in our lab for a week in a plastic bag. So it was pretty bad. And others got boxes of fresh popcorn to eat. And so, we had a week in a plastic bag. So it was pretty bad.|||运动员。每天，数以百万计的人重复着同样的日常生活，而生活却在他们身边溜走。今夏即将上映。作为补偿，我们给了他们一盒盒爆米花吃。现在，在他们不知情的情况下，有些人拿到了隔夜的爆米花，那是我们早些时候爆好并放在实验室塑料袋里保存了一个星期的。所以味道相当糟糕。而另一些人则拿到了新鲜的爆米花吃。所以，我们在塑料袋里放了一个星期。所以味道相当糟糕。
And others got boxes of fresh popcorn. And what we found was this, that people who don't eat popcorn regularly in the movie theater did just what you'd expect. They ate a lot of the fresh popcorn. The stale popcorn they just avoided. What was most interesting though, are the people, the movie patrons, who often ate popcorn in the movie theater.
And others got boxes of fresh popcorn. And what we found was this, that people who don't eat popcorn regularly in the movie theater did just what you'd expect. They ate a lot of the fresh popcorn. The stale popcorn they just avoided. What was most interesting though, are the people, the movie patrons, who often ate popcorn in the movie theater.|||其他人则拿到了新鲜的爆米花的盒子。我们的发现是这样的：那些在电影院不经常吃爆米花的人做出了你所预料的反应。他们吃了大量的新鲜爆米花。而隔夜的爆米花则被他们避之不及。然而，最有趣的是那些经常在电影院吃爆米花的观影者。
They ate 70% of these boxes, whether they were fresh or stale. Now what's so surprising is, we asked them afterwards how much they liked the popcorn and they could all tell us they hated the stale popcorn but to people who have habits the cues are so so strong in that particular context that they just respond to them without thinking and they get the stale popcorn in their mouth and they think, oh, that wasn't great. But then, before they know it, they're back to eating again. That same stuff that they don't like.
They ate 70% of these boxes, whether they were fresh or stale. Now what's so surprising is, we asked them afterwards how much they liked the popcorn and they could all tell us they hated the stale popcorn but to people who have habits the cues are so so strong in that particular context that they just respond to them without thinking and they get the stale popcorn in their mouth and they think, oh, that wasn't great. But then, before they know it, they're back to eating again. That same stuff that they don't like.|||无论新鲜还是隔夜，他们都吃掉了这些盒子里70%的爆米花。令人惊讶的是，事后我们问他们有多喜欢这些爆米花，他们都能告诉我们他们讨厌隔夜的爆米花，但对于有习惯的人来说，在那个特定语境下的线索是如此之强，以至于他们不假思索地做出了反应，当他们把隔夜的爆米花放进嘴里时，他们会想，哦，这个不太好。但随后，在他们意识到之前，他们又开始吃了。吃着同样他们不喜欢的东西。
Wendy added an interesting twist to the study, and this is the part where friction comes in. She ran the same experiment, except this time, she got right-handed volunteers to eat the popcorn with their left hand and left-handed volunteers to eat with their right hand. And that's not something that most of us do on a regular basis. So it made the eating more thoughtful. If you add that thought to the behavior, you make people attend to it, then they quit, that then our strong
Wendy added an interesting twist to the study, and this is the part where friction comes in. She ran the same experiment, except this time, she got right-handed volunteers to eat the popcorn with their left hand and left-handed volunteers to eat with their right hand. And that's not something that most of us do on a regular basis. So it made the eating more thoughtful. If you add that thought to the behavior, you make people attend to it, then they quit, that then our strong|||温迪为这项研究增添了一个有趣的转折，这就是阻力发挥作用的地方。她做了同样的实验，只是这一次，她让右利手（习惯用右手）的志愿者用左手吃爆米花，让左利手的志愿者用右手吃。这不是我们大多数人日常会做的事情。因此，这使得进食过程需要更多的思考。如果你把这种思考加入到行为中，让人们注意到它，那么他们就会停止，这时我们那些有着强烈习惯的参与者停止了吃隔夜的爆米花。
habit participants quit eating the stale popcorn. It's as if if they had to think about it, they realized, oh, this stuff really tastes bad. And so I'm not going to eat it anymore. So in some ways, if I could put this another way, is one of the insights of your work, that if you want to build something into a habit, you actually want to try and make it as unconscious and as automatic as possible. If you want to interrupt a bad habit, you might want to find ways to try and make it just a little bit more conscious, trying to be a little bit more mindful of the habit as you're actually performing it.
habit participants quit eating the stale popcorn. It's as if if they had to think about it, they realized, oh, this stuff really tastes bad. And so I'm not going to eat it anymore. So in some ways, if I could put this another way, is one of the insights of your work, that if you want to build something into a habit, you actually want to try and make it as unconscious and as automatic as possible. If you want to interrupt a bad habit, you might want to find ways to try and make it just a little bit more conscious, trying to be a little bit more mindful of the habit as you're actually performing it.|||习惯参与者停止了吃隔夜的爆米花。就好像如果他们不得不去思考，他们就会意识到，哦，这东西味道真的很糟糕。所以我再也不吃了。所以从某种意义上说，如果我换一种方式表达，你的工作带给我们的见解之一是：如果你想把某件事培养成习惯，你实际上应该努力让它尽可能无意识、尽可能自动化。如果你想打断一个坏习惯，你可能需要想方设法让它变得稍微更有意识一点，在实际执行该习惯时试着保持一点觉知。
Is that an insight that would come away from your work? Yes, yes, I think that's true. And we see people all around us who do those things or don't, right? So people who are very successful as writers, as athletes, they are people who have made the repetition automatic, and they do it every day. You know, you hear about famous writers turning out certain numbers of pages a day, writing for a certain amount of time.
Is that an insight that would come away from your work? Yes, yes, I think that's true. And we see people all around us who do those things or don't, right? So people who are very successful as writers, as athletes, they are people who have made the repetition automatic, and they do it every day. You know, you hear about famous writers turning out certain numbers of pages a day, writing for a certain amount of time.|||这是从你的工作中得出的见解吗？是的，是的，我认为确实如此。我们看到周围的人都在做或者没有做这些事情，对吧？所以那些作为作家、作为运动员非常成功的人，他们都是把重复动作变成自动化的人，并且他们每天都这样做。你知道，你听说过著名作家一天产出一定页数的作品，写作一定的时间。
Athletes work out for certain periods every day. These people have automated the hard work. Doesn't make it, doesn't mean that they're not working hard, but they've made it easier for themselves to do that. If you want to make it more difficult to do something, you want to stop yourself, then you figure out ways to add friction to the behaviors that you don't want to engage in, that makes you stop and think, and perhaps gives you a bit of a chance to realize, oh, this is not really what I intended, maybe I can do something better. You were at a conference in Europe one time, and you used the power of friction to get people to eat more fruit.
Athletes work out for certain periods every day. These people have automated the hard work. Doesn't make it, doesn't mean that they're not working hard, but they've made it easier for themselves to do that. If you want to make it more difficult to do something, you want to stop yourself, then you figure out ways to add friction to the behaviors that you don't want to engage in, that makes you stop and think, and perhaps gives you a bit of a chance to realize, oh, this is not really what I intended, maybe I can do something better. You were at a conference in Europe one time, and you used the power of friction to get people to eat more fruit.|||运动员每天都会锻炼一定的时间。这些人已经将辛苦的工作自动化了。这并不意味着他们不努力，但他们让自己做这件事变得更容易了。如果你想让做某事变得更困难，你想阻止自己，那么你想办法为你不想参与的行为增加阻力，这会让你停下来思考，也许会给你一点机会去意识到，哦，这其实不是我的本意，也许我可以做得更好。你曾在欧洲参加过一次会议，你利用阻力的力量让人们多吃水果。
What did you do Wendy? Oh, well this was actually a conference that I run on habits on Catalina Island here in California, but we had that year a bunch of European participants, and I've noticed that Europeans eat lots of food. So I ordered extra food for them, but the cafeteria folks had put the fruit in a box that was just to the side of the cafeteria line, and no one was eating it. And I noticed it, so I put it right in the middle of the line, and it went immediately. By then, the bananas were a little brownish, but they still, it was obvious, and people, I had made it easy and obvious how to get the fruit, people ate it. In many ways, this is the same insight of the irresistible staircase and Seattle.
What did you do Wendy? Oh, well this was actually a conference that I run on habits on Catalina Island here in California, but we had that year a bunch of European participants, and I've noticed that Europeans eat lots of food. So I order extra food for them, but the cafeteria folks had put the fruit in a box that was just to the side of the cafeteria line, and no one was eating it. And I noticed it, so I put it right in the middle of the line, and it went immediately. By then, the bananas were a little brownish, but they still, it was obvious, and people, I had made it easy and obvious how to get the fruit, people ate it. In many ways, this is the same insight of the irresistible staircase and Seattle.|||温迪，你做了什么？哦，这实际上是我在加利福尼亚州卡特琳娜岛（Catalina Island）举办的一个关于习惯的会议，但那一年我们有一群欧洲参与者，我注意到欧洲人吃很多东西。所以我为他们订购了额外的食物，但自助餐厅的工作人员把水果放在一个刚好在自助餐厅队伍侧面的箱子里，没有人吃。我注意到了这一点，于是我把它直接放在了队伍的正中间，水果马上就被拿光了。到那时，香蕉有点发棕色了，但它们依然很明显，人们——我让获取水果变得既容易又明显，人们就吃了。在许多方面，这与西雅图那个“不可抗拒的楼梯”有着相同的见解。
The architects hid the elevators out of sight, by placing the stairs front and center, by making their use frictionless. The building made it more likely people would unconsciously choose the path of least resistance and climb the stairs. When we come back, how to build our own versions of the irresistible staircase? We look at more ways that we can use friction and other tools to change our habits. Stay with us. There is a recent many of us form bad habits. Things like smoking or gambling have long-term negative consequences,
The architects hid the elevators out of sight, by placing the stairs front and center, by making their use frictionless. The building made it more likely people would unconsciously choose the path of least resistance and climb the stairs. When we come back, how to build our own versions of the irresistible staircase? We look at more ways that we can use friction and other tools to change our habits. Stay with us. There is a recent many of us form bad habits. Things like smoking or gambling have long-term negative consequences,|||建筑师将电梯隐藏在视线之外，将楼梯放在显眼的正中央，通过让使用楼梯变得毫无阻力。这座建筑使得人们更有可能在不知不觉中选择阻力最小的路径并爬楼梯。当我们回来时，如何建立我们自己版本的“不可抗拒的楼梯”？我们将探讨更多可以使用阻力和其他工具来改变习惯的方法。请继续收听。我们许多人最近养成了坏习惯。诸如吸烟或赌博之类的事情会产生长期的消极后果，
but they're extremely rewarding in the short term. Wendy says habits are powerfully shaped by short term rewards. This has to do with the reward component of habits. So what we know about rewards is that our brain responds with dopamine when we get rewarded. And that dopamine is what helps to build the mental associations of habit in our brain. And this means that only certain types of rewards are really going to be useful in forming habits and they're the rewards you experience immediately.
but they're extremely rewarding in the short term. Wendy says habits are powerfully shaped by short term rewards. This has to do with the reward component of habits. So what we know about rewards is that our brain responds with dopamine when we get rewarded. And that dopamine is what helps to build the mental associations of habit in our brain. And this means that only certain types of rewards are really going to be useful in forming habits and they're the rewards you experience immediately.|||但在短期内回报极高。温迪说，习惯在很大程度上是由短期回报塑造的。这与习惯中的奖励机制有关。我们对奖励的了解是，当我们得到奖励时，我们的大脑会用多巴胺做出反应。正是这种多巴胺帮助我们在大脑中建立习惯的心思联想。这意味着只有特定类型的奖励才真正对培养习惯有用，那就是你立即就能体验到的奖励。
Things like exercising or eating healthy food often have tremendous long-term benefits, but they're often not very fun to do. No surprise, they don't produce the quick dopamine bursts. So how do you form habits around healthy behaviors? You have to consciously figure out ways to link these healthy behaviors with short-term rewards. Don't just force yourself to eat more veggies, figure out ways to make the veggies delicious and enjoyable. So if when you eat vegetables, if you really like the taste of beautifully cooked vegetables and you feel pride in eating healthfully and taking care of yourself, those are immediate rewards
锻炼或吃健康食品之类的活动通常有巨大的长期益处，但它们通常不是很有趣。毫无疑问，它们不会产生快速的多巴胺爆发。那么，如何围绕健康行为养成习惯呢？你必须有意识地想办法将这些健康行为与短期奖励联系起来。不要强迫自己吃更多蔬菜，要想办法让蔬菜变得美味可口。因此，当你吃蔬菜时，如果你真的很喜欢烹饪精美的蔬菜的味道，并且为健康饮食和照顾好自己感到自豪，这些就是即时奖励
those are immediate rewards and they will help you build a habit. If your reward is some bonus at the end of the week or something that you give yourself for achieving, say, some health goal, several months down the road, that's not going to be the kind of reward that builds a habit because it's not there when you are acting. So, there's an interesting implication of this, and in some ways it's a sad implication, which is when you think about it, this explains why it's easy to form a habit of eating dessert or smoking or drinking because the rewards when you do those things are relatively quick, an exercise routine or a healthy diet. These are not things where you see the benefit for very long periods of time. Unless, as you say, you develop these intrinsic systems
这些都是即时奖励，它们将帮助你建立习惯。如果你的奖励是周末的某种奖金，或者是你在实现某个健康目标（比如几个月后的某个健康目标）时送给自己的东西，那将不会成为那种能够建立习惯的奖励，因为它在你行动时并不存在。所以，这里有一个有趣的启示，在某些方面这是一个令人沮丧的启示，当你仔细想想，这就解释了为什么养成吃甜点、抽烟或喝酒的习惯很容易，因为当你做这些事情时，奖励相对较快，而锻炼身体或健康饮食则不然。在很长一段时间里，你都看不到这些事情的好处。除非，正如你所说，你发展出了这些内在的系统
to feel pride as you're doing something, not just waiting for the reward three months or three years down the line. That's exactly right. But you have a little bit more control than that because you can add things to behaviors that might not be intrinsically rewarding to you initially. As I said, you can listen to good music when you work out. I hate to admit this. I work out on elliptical some days and that's probably the most boring thing you can do in the world. So I only, I watch competitive cooking shows
让你在做事时感到自豪，而不是只等待三个月或三年后的奖励。完全正确。但你有更多的控制权，因为你可以给那些最初对你没有内在奖励的行为增加一些东西。正如我所说，你可以在锻炼时听好音乐。我很不情愿承认这一点。我有时在椭圆机上锻炼，这可能是世界上最无聊的事情。所以我只看竞技烹饪节目
when I do it. And I only let myself watch those shows when I'm on the elliptical. So that's my reward for working out. And it's made it into quite quite a pleasurable habit, actually. Tell me about your own efforts to become a regular, a habitual jogger. How did that work? What were the obstacles you faced? And how did you try and device methods to overcome them? Oh, this is when my sons were young. I have two sons two years apart in age and I had a full-time job and a husband who had a full-time job. So that was a bit of a challenge to find any time to exercise or do anything else. And that was a real challenge for me early on. For about five years I struggled trying to figure that out.
当我做这件事的时候。我只允许自己在椭圆机上时看那些节目。所以这是我锻炼的奖励。事实上，这已经变成了一个非常愉快的习惯。跟我聊聊你自发成为一名定期慢跑者的努力。那是怎么做到的？你遇到了什么障碍？你是如何尝试设计方法来克服它们的？哦，这是在我儿子们还小的时候。我有两个儿子，年龄相差两岁，我有一份全职工作，丈夫也有一份全职工作。所以找时间锻炼或做其他事情确实是一个挑战。这对我早期来说是一个真正的挑战。大约五年的时间里，我一直在努力弄清楚这一点。
If you have little kids, you know, you say, I'm going to work out today at four o'clock. And then one of them gets sick or another has a friend who comes over and you can't leave or leave them. Something always comes up. And then with your job on top of it, it was just, it was impossible. Every night I'd go back and I'd go to bed and I'd be like, okay, another failure. Until I decided that I was going to have to find a time when I could do it regularly, consistently, and that was early in the morning. So I started running, I was a committed runner for many years.
如果你有小孩子，你知道的，你会说，我今天四点钟要锻炼。然后其中一个生病了，或者另一个有朋友来家里，你不能离开或者撇下他们。总会有事情发生。再加上你的工作，这简直是不可能的。每天晚上我回到家上床睡觉时，都会想，好吧，又失败了。直到我决定必须找到一个可以定期、持续锻炼的时间，那就是清晨。所以我开始跑步，我做了很多年的坚定跑者。
I started running at six in the morning. And that was very hard to start off with because for me, that didn't come naturally. And I really dreaded that. But it got easier each time. And I actually did listen to the radio. And I found that to be a great sort of way to wake up, ultimately, to just, one of the things I did to help was,
我从早上六点开始跑步。一开始非常难，因为对我来说，这并不是自然而然的。我真的很害怕这个。但每次都变得容易了。事实上我确实听了收音机。我发现这最终是一种很好的醒来方式，为了提供帮助，我做的事情之一就是，
I'm telling you all of my secrets here, I actually slept in my running clothes because it made it easier to then get up and just get out the door early in the morning. And then if I got back by seven o'clock, then I could make my boys breakfast and see them off to school and go live the rest of my day without having this worry about how I was going to get exercise in given the rest of my schedule. So it worked.
我在这里把所有的秘密都告诉你了，我实际上穿着跑步衣服睡觉，因为这更容易让我起床，然后大清早在清晨出门。如果我在七点钟前回来的话，我就可以给我的男孩们做早晨，送他们去上学，然后继续我一天的生活，而不必担心在剩余的日程安排中如何进行锻炼。所以这成功了。
So what I find so interesting about that is that our conscious minds in some ways can help, but they help primarily not so much in terms of exercising willpower, but in scheming our ways to make the habit as frictionless as possible. And so in some ways your conscious mind came up with this idea to say, let me sleep in my jogging clothes.
所以我对这一点感到非常有趣的是，我们的意识在某些方面可以提供帮助，但它们的主要作用与其说是发挥意志力，不如说是想方设法让习惯变得尽可能顺畅。所以在某种程度上，你的意识想出了这个主意，说，让我穿着慢跑服睡觉吧。
So when the alarm goes off at six o'clock, I don't have the thought in my head, oh no, I have to spend time changing before I go out, you've just made it a little more frictionless, a little more easy. Exactly. It's sort of like what professional chefs do. So I went up to the Culinary Institute of America and took a few of their preliminary classes, how they trained chefs in something called Mieson-Plaas, which is how to set up your environment to make it easy to create great dishes, consistently great dishes each time. And they described to me the dilemma of beginning chefs, is they wanted to just jump in and do it. Let's just do it. And they would get some flour, some sugar,
所以当六点的闹钟响起来的时候，我的脑海里不会冒出“哦不，我出门前还得花时间换衣服”的想法，你只是让事情变得更顺畅了一点，更容易了一点。完全正确。这有点像专业厨师的做法。所以我去了美国烹饪学院并参加了他们的一些初级课程，他们如何培训厨师掌握一种叫做“备料”（Mise-en-place）的技术，也就是如何设置你的环境，以便轻松地创作出美味的菜肴，每一次都能做出持续美味的菜肴。他们向我描述了初学者厨师的困境，他们只想直接跳进去做。让我们直接开始吧。他们会拿一些面粉、一些糖、
some of the components together, and they'd try to start creating stuff. But then they'd figure out, oh, no, I really need more flour. And I wasn't supposed to put all the sugar in here and I was supposed to do something else there. And so they have to learn, this is when they learn mise en place putting everything in place before they actually begin and they put it in place in order. So they're not thinking a lot, they're not making decisions while they're actually cooking.
把一些组件组合在一起，然后尝试开始制作东西。但随后他们会发现，哦，不，我真的需要更多的面粉。我本不应该把所有的糖都放进这里的，我本应该在别的地方做点别的。所以他们必须学习，这就是他们学习“备料”的时候，在开始之前把所有东西都放到位，并按顺序摆放好。这样他们就不用想太多，在实际烹饪时也不需要做太多决定。
Instead, they are cute by all of the implements and the food and the prepared items in front of them on what goes next, and it makes it much easier for them to be consistent and actually produce the same thing. And I was impressed with that as a metaphor for behavior change because if you structure the environment ahead of time, yes it's work, yes it does take executive control, our conscious thinking cells, but then we make it so much easier for us to sort of automate all of the other decisions so that in their case they can think about ways to make it their current cakes even more wonderful and pastries even tastier as they put them together. They can put the flourish into them because they have
相反，他们面前的所有用具、食物和准备好的物品会提示他们接下来该做什么，这让他们更容易保持一致并实际产出相同的东西。作为一个关于行为改变的隐喻，这给我留下了深刻的印象，因为如果你提前规划好环境，是的，这是工作，是的，它确实需要执行控制，即我们的意识思考细胞，但随后它让我们更容易将所有其他决策自动化，以便在他们的情况下，他们可以思考如何把他们目前的蛋糕做得更精彩，糕点在组合时更加美味。他们可以把精湛的技艺融入其中，因为他们已经
automated the basic components. Wendy says you can also use friction in the opposite direction to disrupt a habit. Think about campaigns to limit smoking. By the time the Surgeon General's report came out on the dangers of smoking, people had a pretty good idea. It convinced people that they needed to stop smoking. But in fact, sales of cigarettes in the US continued to increase into the 70s. So people were convinced they knew it was not good for them,
将基本组件自动化了。温迪说，你还可以利用相反方向的摩擦力来打破习惯。想想限制吸烟的运动。当外科医生的吸烟危害报告出来时，人们对吸烟的危害有了相当不错的了解。它说服人们需要戒烟。但事实上，美国香烟的销量在70年代继续增长。所以人们被说服了，他们知道吸烟对他们没有好处，
but they kept doing it. It was only once we started modifying the environment. So warning labels on cigarette packs. We removed vending machines, I don't know if you remember cigarette vending machines, but you can't find them anymore because there are now rules about how you can purchase cigarettes. Sigarettes are typically put behind the counter, and you have to ask for them in order to purchase them. We set bands on smoking in public places, so that you can't easily anymore just light up in your office,
但他们还是继续抽。直到我们开始改变环境。比如香烟包装上的警告标签。我们撤下了自动售货机，我不知道你是否还记得香烟自动售货机，但你再也找不到它们了，因为现在有了关于如何购买香烟的规定。香烟通常放在柜台后面，你必须要求才能购买。我们在公共场所对吸烟实施了禁令，这样你就不再能轻易地在办公室里点烟了，
in a restaurant, on a plane. And then we started taxing cigarettes. All of that took huge political decision-making and commitment to make it happen. But isn't it fascinating, Wendy, that telling people that smoking is going to give them, you know, emphysema and lung cancer, that these things in some ways are less effective than telling them they have to walk a hundred yards,
在餐馆里，在飞机上。然后我们开始对香烟征税。所有这些都需要巨大的政治决策和承诺才能实现。但是，温迪，告诉人们吸烟会导致肺气肿和肺癌，在某些方面这些效果不如告诉他们必须步行一百码，从办公桌前站起来，走出大楼，在外面点烟来得有效，这难道不是很迷人吗？
get up from that desk, walk outside the building, and light up outside. You would think that the first would actually have much more effect than the second, but that does not turn out to be the case. You're right. We're pitiful. We would like to think that we are rational and respond to the data on cancer and emphysema, but the reality is we tend to act on autopilot on what we are doing already because it's so much easier. It's very hard to exert that kind of control. So in a way, what the government was doing is it was making it easier for us
你可能会认为前者实际上比后者产生更多效果，但事实并非如此。你说得对。我们真可怜。我们愿意认为自己是理性的，会对癌症和肺气肿的数据做出反应，但现实是，我们往往在做我们已经在做的事情时表现得像个自动驾驶仪，因为这容易得多。要施加那种控制是非常困难的。所以在某种程度上，政府正在做的是让我们更容易
to do the thing that we already wanted to do, which is to smoke less. We've talked about how you can decrease friction to build good habits and increase friction to dismantle bad habits. We've looked at how you can make healthy behaviors automatic and mindless and make unhealthy behaviors conscious and effortful. Here are three additional ideas that build on these insights. The first is something that Wendy calls piggybacking or stacking.
去做我们本就想做的事情，那就是少抽烟。我们讨论了如何减少摩擦来建立好习惯，以及如何增加摩擦来消除坏习惯。我们探讨了如何使健康行为变得自动化和不费脑，以及如何使不健康行为变得有意识和费力。这里有三个额外的想法，它们建立在这些见解之上。第一个是温迪称之为“搭便车”或“叠加”的方法。
It is taking a behavior that you're already doing and inserting a new behavior that you want to add. So, you want to remember to take your meds. Maybe you have meds prescribed by your doctor that you're supposed to take every night. If you want to remember to take them, a good way to do it is to put it on your nightstand and then whatever you do last before you get into bed is it turn off your phone, set your alarm, whatever it is, just insert taking that pill in that stream of behavior and over time it will become automated much like the automated pattern that you're already performing.
这是指采用你已经在做的行为，并插入你想要添加的新行为。所以，你想要记住吃药。也许你的医生给你开了药，要求你每晚服用。如果你想记住吃药，一个好方法是把它放在床头柜上，然后你在上床睡觉前做的最后一件事就是关掉手机、设置闹钟，无论是什么，只需将吃药这个动作插入到那个行为流中，随着时间的推移，它就会变得自动化，就像你已经在执行的自动化模式一样。
In other words, you can essentially string habits together like a chain. Yes. Yeah. It's a sort of a shortcut to forming a new habit. Use one that you already have. Another powerful insight has to do with the role of what Wendy calls cues, things that prompt you to do something. Wendy mentioned cues in the context of the popcorn study. If you've ever been a smoker, you might have noticed that there are certain triggers to your smoking. Maybe you come home at the end of the day and you light up on your front porch.
换句话说，你本质上可以像链条一样把习惯串联起来。是的。是的。这是一种形成新习惯的捷径。利用你已经拥有的习惯。另一个强有力的见解与温迪所谓的线索（能够促使你做某事的事物）的作用有关。温迪在爆米花研究的背景下提到了线索。如果你曾经是个烟民，你可能已经注意到抽烟有一些特定的诱因。也许你一天的晚些时候回到家，在你的前廊点上一支烟。
The porch is what Wendy calls a queue. Cues are very powerful in creating new habits or preserving old ones. Wendy uses cues in her own life to build new habits. One cue for her is to wake up and have breakfast with her husband. That's her signal, her cue, that the next thing she needs to do is sit down at her computer and write for two hours. If I give myself a couple of hours in the morning to write, if I structure it into my schedule, then I take away all of the decision-making and the stress about when and where I'm going
门廊就是温迪所说的线索。线索在建立新习惯或维护旧习惯方面非常强大。温迪在自己的生活中使用线索来建立新习惯。对她来说的一个线索是醒来并与丈夫共进早餐。那是她的信号，她的线索，表明她接下来需要做的事情是坐在电脑前写两个小时的文章。如果我在早晨给自己留出几个小时来写作，如果我把它安排在我的日程表中，那么我就消除了所有关于何时何地进行的决策和压力
to do it. I don't mean to say that it makes writing easy. Writing is always a challenge for everyone, But it does make the process easier, so I'm not all the time struggling about whether I should be doing this or something else. That's being decided. This is part of my job and I just need to do it. There's one last source of new habits, and it comes from an unexpected place.
去做这件事。我并不是说这让写作变得容易。写作对每个人来说都是一个挑战，但它确实让过程变得更容易，所以我不会一直在纠结我是否应该做这件事或其他事情。这已经决定了。这是我工作的一部分，我只需要去做。产生新习惯的最后一个源头，它来自一个意想不到的地方。
Chaos. There's one last source of new habits and it comes from an unexpected place. Chaos. When our lives go haywire, the cues that normally surround us disappear. Wendy says this can be a profound opportunity for reinvention. There's actually been a lot of research on something called habit discontinuity, it's a jargonny term, but it is studies of people when they're undergoing change. And what we've learned is that that's an opportunity for people to try out new things
混乱。产生新习惯的最后一个源头，它来自一个意想不到的地方。混乱。当我们的生活陷入混乱时，通常环绕我们的线索就会消失。温迪说这可能是一个重塑自我的深远机遇。事实上，关于一种叫做“习惯中断”的东西有很多研究，这是一个听起来很专业的术语，但它是对处于变革中的人们的研究。我们了解到，对于人们来说，这是一个尝试新事物的机会
that they didn't have the chance to do at, say, an old job or an old place where they lived. There's many such life disruptions, right? Relationships and you get a family, life gets disrupted, and the typical way we think about that is that that's stressful and that that's not a good time for making new decisions. But in fact, it actually turns out to be an opportunity for them to act more authentically on their values. So because they're making those decisions,
这是他们在旧工作或旧居住地没有机会做的事情。有很多这样的生活变故，对吧？人际关系和组建家庭，生活被打乱了，我们对此的典型看法是，这很有压力，而且这不是做新决定的好时机。但事实上，这最终被证明是他们更真实地行使价值观的机会。所以因为他们在做那些决定，
they have to think, do I want to do this? How do I do this? What are my new choices here? It's an opportunity to rethink some of the practical decisions you've made in your life and maybe to act more in ways that are consistent with how you want to be. Wendy Wood is a professor of psychology and business at the University of Southern California. She's the author of Good Habits, Bad Habits, the science of making positive changes that stick.
他们必须思考，我想这么做吗？我该怎么做？我这里的新选择是什么？这是一个重新思考你在生活中做出的实际决定的机会，也许能够更多地按照你希望成为的样子去行动。温迪·伍德是南加州大学的心理学和商业教授。她是《好习惯，坏习惯：持久改变的科学》一书的作者。
Wendy, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was lovely to talk to you, thank you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Mid-Roll Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung heroes this week are Noah Carnahan and Rob Harris.
温迪，谢谢你今天来到《隐秘大脑》。很高兴跟你聊天，谢谢。由隐秘大脑传媒制作。Mid-Roll 传媒是我们独家的广告销售合作伙伴。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德里克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是隐秘大脑的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是诺亚·卡纳汉和罗布·哈里斯。
Noah and Rob make sure audio sounds good on all the different platforms we are heard on from podcasting apps to websites. Some time ago we had some problems translating the audio we were hearing in our headphones into the right format for all these different platforms. NOAA and Rob worked with us into the wee hours, always maintaining that composure as we played detective, trying to get to the heart of the problem. We're so grateful. We're thinking of doing an episode in 2021 about second chances. If you have a great personal
诺亚和罗布确保音频在我们在其上被听到的所有不同平台上都听起来很好，从播客应用程序到网站。不久前，我们在将耳机中听到的音频转换为适合所有这些不同平台的正确格式时遇到了一些问题。诺亚和罗布与我们一直工作到深夜，当我们像侦探一样试图找到问题核心时，他们总是保持着这种沉着。我们非常感激。我们正在考虑在2021年制作一集关于第二次机会的节目。如果你有一个精彩的个人
story about a second chance that you received, Please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo on your phone. Email it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org with the subject line, second chances. Again find a quiet room, record a voice memo and send it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. If you liked this episode, please share it with someone who doesn't know much about podcasting. If they need help, please show them how to subscribe to our show. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Happy New Year. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
关于你获得的第二次机会的故事，请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录制一封简短的语音备忘录。将其发送电子邮件至 ideas@hiddenbrain.org，主题行写上“第二次机会”。再次强调，找一个安静的房间，录制语音备忘录并发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。如果你喜欢这一集，请把它分享给一个对播客了解不多的人。如果他们需要帮助，请向他们展示如何订阅我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。新年快乐。这集节目还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子来发表评论。